my name is Joe Chang I am the CTO of
posit most days I co-lead the shiny team
with Winston Chang
the shiny really started with the
request from one of our users one of our
earliest users of our studio IDE
Professor Danny Kaplan asked us for an
interactive way to present
statistical and math concepts to
students and he knew R really well so he
wanted to do it with r
so it wasn't until probably a year after
he had made this request that I stumbled
onto a technology called meteor that
was pushing this new to me very alien
form of programming called reactive
programming and it took me a while to
get my head around how it actually
worked and a little digging through
their source code
but finally after I understood what they
were doing and some time had passed
where I guess my brain could marinated
it
I woke up one morning and I just had
this vision of
HTML with no JavaScript in it
just simple markup that had indicators
of what elements were inputs and what
elements were outputs
combined that with
reactive code written in r
that would power that HTML interface and
tie it all together with a websocket
connection it really felt like this
could be a way to build applications
that were interactive enough to satisfy
the needs of not just Danny but a lot of
Danny's out there in the auto world and
I think shiny will always find its
purest expression in R just because of
how flexible the language is but it's
impossible to ignore how many people
could benefit
if we bring those same ideas to python
as well
the design of the language really
prioritizes ease of understanding and
ease of reading
whereas I think in R we tend to favor
concise expression of our ideas
and maybe a certain Elegance in Symmetry
and in Python
readability
understandability Simplicity those are
valued more
so I think for some people
python is just home I mean it's famously
the second best language for anything
right I think that's a label that
pythonistas probably wear with pride
and because python is the second best
language for anything it means that if
we want to reach more people with shiny
we can reach all those people for whom
python is useful and that's a lot of
people
[Music]